ich habe zwei fragen an euch zuerst mal
an caruso was sind deine vorbilder in
sachen rap beziehungsweise was hast du
so am anfang an gehört und einmal an
euch beide warum solche guten muss ich
mein herz ich irgendwie andere masken
auch getan
hallo bernd peters die erste frage war
vorbilder was wir früher gehört haben ja
wir haben das gehört was uns große
brüder usw gezeigt haben das war viel
gutes
busta rhymes an mir ab fiel aber
natürlich auch deutsche sachen
westberlin maskulin sauber schon taktlos
alles gehört so keine ahnung alles was
damals alles was damals cool war azad
freundeskreis in deutschland haben wir
alles gehört so und wenn du jetzt nach
hip hop wird natürlich noch andere
sachen aus anderen bereichen aber das
war so die bleibt also die rap sachen
die wir gehört haben und die zweite
frage warum wo du mussten sie doch cool
aus leder oder lang smokie fragt von wo
kommt der name genetik groß claudia
claudio gem
der name genetik kommt von daher hätte
so etwas individuelles wollten und
einfach nichts individueller ist als die
genetik an sich party fragt mit wem
macht ihr am nächsten ein feature er
meint wohl eher im moment haben wir erst
mal viel musik für euch gemacht das
heißt das steht gar nichts an jetzt
demnächst ehrlich gesagt wenn das nicht
mitgekriegt hat haben wir mad men
feature dass wir veröffentlichen werden
innerhalb der nächsten tag ich weiß nur
dass sie ausgestrahlt wird am 12 juli
und dann lass es aber sonst ist nichts
geplant
hey jungs von genetik meine frage ist
wie genau seid ihr denn aus musik maria
kommen das würde mich wirklich
interessieren dann würde mich sehr über
eine antwort freuen
haut rein wie kommt man zum musikmachen
keine ahnung wie kommst du zum
fußballspielen oder so ein haus bock
drauf und dann stoppt die paar jungs und
schieß los keine ahnung da stolpert man
halt rein keine ahnung wie wir haben uns
auf das war eine kleine geschichte dazu
gibt es irgendwann mal auf irgend eine
hausparty auf der wir uns getroffen
haben
und da wir sind wer umgestürzt und haben
diverse sachen gemacht aber nicht
sprechen will jetzt um die jugend nicht
zu verrohen und da hat sich dann mit zu
dem kopf auf die idee dass wir doch
vielleicht musik machen sollen und so
sind wir zum mutmachen gekommen brad
bird li möchte weder fond du bist weg
persönlichen bezug also habt ihr das
selber erlebt muss man ihn fragen
ich möchte auf diese frage als könig der
lügner medien antworten
juli amélie sagen das ist warum fragt
ihr jetzt machen anstatt euch zu
schminken
ich fand mit schminke sei es genial aus
also ich finde mit maske sieht noch
besser aus
und weil es einfach auf dauer nicht ging
mit live auch in interviews jetzt ist
wird zu umständlich gewesen
9 caruso und ich hab ein paar fragen an
euch erstmal wie seid ihr auf den namen
danek berlin gekommen
interessiert euch für den kosmos oder
ist ja irgendwie so entstanden und
werdet nur die natur geben oder werden
da auch mal gäste wie kollege oder
favorite oder so dabei sein
jonas war schon meine fragen hier
ich unterstütze gute musik und show also
du hast das album kauf dankeschön dafür
ein aufrichtiges danke die box sogar hat
er sich bestellt ok sehr cool gemacht
gute sache dankeschön dafür erstmal und
also geplant ist nicht oft vor dass
irgend jemand vorbeikommt unsere eigene
tools unser album dna live das heißt man
muss nicht auszuschließen dass mal ein
gast irgendwo vorbeikommt wenn der bock
drauf hat und wir auch aber setzt nicht
eingeplant und der braker aliens
ja wir haben bei dem album uns mehr
gedanken zum konzept gemacht sozusagen
und dieses alien motiv sozusagen von von
einer anderen welt
andere musik machen andere hip hop als
die anderen im idealfall hat halt
einfach zu dem thema gepasst und deshalb
danek break aliens außerdem passt
natürlich die das kürzel der nato zu
genetik und deswegen hat es gepasst